At the end of March, New York magazine published a story with a title, is my chest tightness anxiety or the coronavirus? The author was concerned because for days, she felt tightness in her chest. That can be a symptom of COVID-19, but it's also a symptom of anxiety. In the last couple of months, many of us have become familiar with the feeling of fear, expressing itself in our bodies. We may feel restless, physically exhausted. At times, we may even have trouble catching our breath.
三月底，《纽约》杂志发表了一篇题为“我的胸闷是焦虑还是冠状病毒？”的文章。作者感到担忧，因为她连续几天感到胸口发紧。这可能是2019冠状病毒病的症状，但也是焦虑的症状。在过去几个月中，我们许多人都对这种恐惧在体内显现的感觉习以为常。我们可能会感到烦躁不安、身体精疲力竭。有时，我们甚至会呼吸困难。
This deep connection between mind and body made us think about an episode we did a while back, about a dimension of medicine that few of us recognize. And we thought we'd bring it back today as a reminder of how our minds are tied to our physical suffering, and the complex ways in which healing unfolds. Here's the episode. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. When you're eight years old, it's not easy to say goodbye to your dad for a whole year. But that's what Andrew Marvin had to do. His dad was a commander in the Navy and was deployed to Bahrain.
这种身心之间的深厚联系让我们想起了不久前的一期节目，内容关于一个很少有人了解的医学维度。今天我们决定重新播出这期节目，以提醒大家我们的精神是如何与肉体痛苦联系在一起的，以及疗愈过程的复杂方式。以下是这期节目。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。当你八岁时，要跟爸爸告别整整一年可不容易。但安德鲁·马尔文就不得不这样做。他的爸爸是海军指挥官，被派驻到巴林。
While his dad was away, something happened to Andrew. Every time my husband's name was brought up, he would develop a headache. This is Andrew's mom, Anne-Marie Marvin. She knew her son's pain was real. She didn't want him to suffer. As she tried to figure out how to help, she remembered an episode of the TV show, Mash. The series is set in a fictionalized army hospital.
在爸爸不在期间，安德鲁身上发生了一些事。每当我丈夫的名字被提起，他就会头痛。这是安德鲁的妈妈安妮-玛丽·马尔文。她知道儿子的痛是真实存在的。她不想让他受苦。当她试图找出帮助他的方法时，她想起了电视剧《陆军流动医院》中的一集。该剧以虚构的军队医院为背景。
Come on guys, let's go back to the tent, come on. The doctors had a problem on their hands. The hospital was full of wounded soldiers, but was out of painkillers. A Colonel suggested an unusual solution, treat the patients with a placebo. Here's the formula. If we believe it, they believe it.
来吧，伙计们，我们回帐篷去，快点。医生们遇到棘手的问题了。医院里挤满了受伤的士兵，但止痛药却用完了。一位上校提出了一个不同寻常的解决方案——用安慰剂治疗患者。秘诀在此。如果我们相信，他们就会相信。
Otherwise, they're only taking sugar pills. The doctors gave out the placebo's, while pretending they were real pills. Sure enough, it worked. You're really beginning to feel it, aren't you, son? Yeah, the iron stuff's rubbing. It's going to feel even better now, it's some sleep. The lesson Anne-Marie took away from the scene was, make the placebo treatment look real. So I went to the store and I got a bottle of motron and I got a bottle of chewable vitamin C tablets and I switched the bottles.
否则，他们吃的就只是糖丸。医生们分发安慰剂，同时假装它们是真药。果然，它起作用了。你真的开始感觉到了，对吧，孩子？对，那个铁质的东西在摩擦。现在感觉会更舒服一些，这是安眠药。安妮-玛丽从这一幕中得到的启教是：把安慰剂治疗做得像真的一样。所以我去商店买了一瓶美林，又买了一瓶可咀嚼维生素C片，然后把药瓶调换了。
As Anne-Marie gave Andrew the vitamins, she made sure the lie didn't look like a lie. I would emphasize that he had to really have a headache. I would treat it as a would a regular drug that I wouldn't want to medicate unless absolutely necessary. On a couple rare occasions, he said it didn't work and asked for a second pill. I would make him wait 20 minutes to see if it would work first. As I would a regular medication for I let him take a second one, I emphasize that I couldn't do any more than that because of the dose.
当安妮-玛丽把维生素给安德鲁时，她确保这个谎言看起来不露痕迹。我会强调他确实需要头痛药。我会像对待常规药物一样对待它，除非绝对必要，否则我不想给他用药。在极少数情况下，他说没用并要求吃第二粒。我会让他等20分钟，先看看它是否起作用。就像对待常规药物一样，在他服用第二粒之前，我强调因为剂量问题，我不能再给他吃更多了。
Every single time we use the placebo, the headache went away, usually within about a half an hour. Anne Marie's small act of parental deception raises lots of questions. If you can make a child's headaches disappear with a vitamin, what else can you do with a placebo? What was happening in Andrew's mind and body as he took the pills? How much was the cure linked to the rituals that An-Marie built into the treatment. Perhaps most difficult of all, can you get the same results without deception? These are not questions doctors generally ask.
每次我们使用安慰剂时，头痛都会消失，通常在大约半小时内。安妮-玛丽小小的为人父母的欺骗行为引发了许多问题。如果你能用一颗维生素让孩子的头痛消失，你还能用安慰剂做到什么？安德鲁在服药时，他的大脑和身体里发生了什么？疗效在多大程度上与安妮-玛丽在治疗中构建的仪式感有关？也许最困难的是，不通过欺骗你能得到同样的结果吗？这些通常不是医生会问的问题。
For centuries, scientists have used placebo mainly to deflate the claims of con men and to test the efficacy of drugs and medical interventions. This week on Hidden Brain, what it means to be sick and what it means to heal and the powerful tool that modern medicine has overlooked. 1996 was quite the year for men's basketball. It's the year that Space Jam, starring Michael Made it to theaters. It was also the year of Dream Team 3. That was the nickname given to the 1996 US men's Olympic basketball team. They dominated the court in Atlanta. Is that the year we won the gold?
几个世纪以来，科学家使用安慰剂主要是为了驳斥江湖骗子的谎言，并测试药物和医疗干预措施的疗效。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨生病的意义、疗愈的意义，以及现代医学忽视的强大工具。1996年对男子篮球来说是不寻常的一年。那是迈克尔主演的《空中大灌篮》上映的年份。这也是“梦三队”的年份。那是1996年美国男子奥运篮球队的绰号。他们在亚特兰大的球场上统治全场。那是我们赢得金牌的那一年吗？
We win the court in Atlanta. Is that the year we won the gold? Oh, we win the gold every year. Yeah. They are headed to the gold medal. This is Bruce Mosley. If you look closely at old videos of those games, you can see him sitting near the sidelines, wearing a sport jacket and tie. He was one of the physicians for the team. You might recognize some of the players Bruce is treated.
我们在亚特兰大称霸球场。那是我们赢得金牌的那一年吗？哦，我们每年都赢得金牌。是的。他们正朝着金牌迈进。这是布鲁斯·莫斯利。如果你仔细看那些比赛的旧录像，你可以看到他坐在场边，身穿运动夹克打着领带。他是球队的队医之一。你可能认得布鲁斯治疗过的一些球员。
Ikeem Alajuan, Shaquille O'Neal, David Robinson, Charles Barkley, Carl Malone, John Stockton, Mitch Richmond. For years, Bruce worked as an orthopedic surgeon for the Houston NBA team, The Rockets. He performed lots of intricate surgeries. He loved seeing players glide across the court and soar in the air. He would think, that done? I have to make that happen. In a way, that's my knee.
奥拉朱旺、沙奎尔·奥尼尔、大卫·罗宾逊、查尔斯·巴克利、卡尔·马龙、约翰·斯托克顿、米奇·里奇蒙德。多年来，布鲁斯一直担任休斯顿NBA球队火箭队的骨科医生。他做过许多复杂的手术。他喜欢看球员在球场上滑行并在空中翱翔。他会想，做到了吗？我必须让它发生。从某种意义上说，那是我的膝盖。
Bruce's exceptional surgical skill is what makes it so surprising that he, of all people, would lead a study that questions the primacy of surgical skill. Did I ever see myself doing this? The answer is absolutely not, and it wasn't my idea. Let's back up a second. In 1989, years before he was a physician for the rockets, Bruce started working at the Baylor College of Medicine in Houston. He became interested in a knee surgery that's meant to help people with arthritis. It wasn't a common surgery where he received his medical training.
布鲁斯出色的外科手术技能，使得他——偏偏是他——会领导一项质疑外科手术技能至上地位的研究，这让人感到非常惊讶。我曾想过自己会做这种事吗？答案是绝对没有，而且这不是我的主意。让我们倒回一点。1989年，在他担任火箭队队医的多年前，布鲁斯开始在休斯顿的贝勒医学院工作。他开始对一种旨在帮助关节炎患者的膝关节手术产生兴趣。在他接受医学培训的地方，这不是一门常见的手术。
And then when I came here to Houston, it seemed like surgeons were doing it almost nonstop. He found it odd that surgeons in some parts of the country were doing the procedure far more often than others. Patients reported feeling better after the surgery, but no one knew why. Was it because surgeons scrape away bits of tissue from the joint? Was that alleviating the pain? Or could it simply be an effect of saltwater? As part of the procedure, surgeons flush the knee with saline solution.
然后当我来到休斯顿后，似乎外科医生们几乎在不停地做这个手术。他发现奇怪的是，全国某些地区的外科医生做这种手术的频率远高于其他地区。患者报告说手术后感觉好些了，但没有人知道原因。是因为外科医生刮掉了关节上的部分组织吗？那是为了缓解疼痛吗？还是仅仅是盐水的作用？作为手术的一部分，外科医生会用盐水冲洗膝盖。
Bruce wanted to run a trial to answer these questions. One set of patients would get the standard surgery. Another would just get their joint flushed with saline. He went to a colleague to discuss his plan. When I pitched it, she was the one that said, well, how do you know it's not all a placebo effect? A placebo effect. The same phenomenon that helped eight-year-old Andrew Marvin and the soldiers in MASH. As a surgeon, I was like, this doesn't have anything to do with sugar pills and things like that. This is surgery, after all.
布鲁斯想进行一项试验来回答这些问题。一组患者将接受标准手术。另一组则只用盐水冲洗关节。他去找一位同事讨论他的计划。当我提出这个想法时，她是那个说“嗯，你怎么知道这不全是安慰剂效应呢？”的人。安慰剂效应。那个曾帮助八岁儿童安德鲁·马尔文以及《陆军流动医院》里的士兵的相同现象。作为一名外科医生，我觉得这跟糖丸之类的一点关系都没有。毕竟，这是手术。
I was like, this doesn't have anything to do with sugar pills and things like that. This is surgery after all. But Bruce's colleague explained to him that the placebo effect comes in many shapes and sizes. If it's a small pill, sometimes there's not as big a placebo effect as a bigger pill, or if they say it's a new and exciting pill, there's probably more of a placebo effect than a traditional pill. And many times an injection can have more of a placebo effect than a pill, and many times some other intervention can have more of a placebo effect than an injection, and perhaps surgery may have the biggest placebo effect
我觉得这跟糖丸之类的一点关系都没有。毕竟，这是手术。但布鲁斯的同事向他解释说，安慰剂效应有多种形状和大小。如果是小药丸，有时安慰剂效应不如大药丸那么大；或者如果他们说这是一种新奇刺激的药丸，其安慰剂效应可能比传统药丸更大。而且很多时候，注射的安慰剂效应可能比药丸更大，很多时候其他一些干预措施的安慰剂效应可能比注射更大，也许手术可能会产生最大的安慰剂效应
of all. Sogins like brews don't think about these questions very much because the idea of comparing actual treatment to placebo treatment isn't built into the practice of surgery. If you're trying to bring a new medication to the market, you have to go through all kinds of randomized trials including, you know, a placebo, and prove that your product is superior to the placebo treatment group. Well, surgeries don't go through that same scrutiny. Surgeries are many times adopted because it's an improvement over a previous surgery, which is an improvement on a previous surgery, which is an
这一切。像布鲁斯这样的外科医生并不经常思考这些问题，因为将实际治疗与安慰剂治疗进行比较的概念并未内置于外科手术的实践中。如果你试图将一种新药推向市场，你必须经历各种随机试验，包括（你知道的）安慰剂，并证明你的产品优于安慰剂治疗组。嗯，手术并没有经历这种审查。外科手术往往被采用，是因为它对前一个手术进行了改进，而前一个手术又是对前一个手术的改进，前一个手术又是对
improvement on one before that, and long story short, very few surgeries ever go through randomized trials and almost no surgeries have a placebo control group. Bruce and his team decided their study would have not two but three groups. The first would get the real surgery. The second would have saline washed through the joint. The third would be a placebo group. Anyone who signed up was informed
更早之前的改进，长话短说，极少有外科手术经历过随机对照试验，几乎没有任何外科手术设有安慰剂对照组。布鲁斯和他的团队决定他们的研究将不设两组，而是三组。第一组将接受真实手术。第二组将用盐水冲洗关节。第三组将是安慰剂组。任何报名的人都会被告知
about the three possible kinds of treatment. We told them going in, you're going to get randomized to one of three groups, and these are the three groups. And we actually had them sign a piece of paper that said, I understand that I may be randomized to a control group that is a placebo group and placebo means pretend and that if I'm in this group I'll have a pretend
关于三种可能的治疗方法。我们在一开始就告诉他们，你们将被随机分到三组中的一组，这就是这三组。我们甚至让他们在一张纸上签字，上面写着：我明白我可能会被随机分到一个对照组，即安慰剂组，而安慰剂意味着假装；如果我在这组中，我将接受假的手术
surgery not a real surgery and they had to write it in their own handwriting to make sure that they fully understood everything we were saying. The researchers followed certain procedures to make sure all three types of surgeries felt real to everyone involved. real to the patients and their families, and is real as possible to the physicians. Bruce would put on his crops and walk into the OR without knowing what type of surgery he was going to perform. He found out only when he opened an envelope.
而不是真实的手术。他们必须亲笔手写下来，以确保他们完全理解我们所说的一切。研究人员遵循了某些程序，以确保所有这三种类型的手术对相关的所有人来说都感觉真实——对患者及其家属真实，并对医生尽可能真实。布鲁斯会穿上刷手服走进手术室，却不知道自己要做什么类型的手术。只有当他打开一个信封时，他才会知道。
The patient would be wheeled into the room, they'd be placed onto the table, and once they're on the table we would open the randomization envelope which would disclose which of the three groups there would be placed into. All the patients were given general anesthesia. All got incisions in their knees. Patients in the first two groups received surgery or got their knees flushed with saline. And then the third group, the placebo group, they would go to sleep and make three little holes in the skin. And then I wouldn't put any instruments actually inside the knee joint itself. Instead, Bruce fired up a video. I had a video tape of a real arthroscopy that had done on a patient and I would pop it
患者会被推入房间，放在手术台上，一旦他们上了手术台，我们就会打开随机化信封，其中会披露他们将被分配到哪三组中。所有患者都接受了全身麻醉。所有人的膝盖上都有切口。前两组患者接受了手术或用盐水冲洗了膝盖。然后是第三组，即安慰剂组，他们会进入睡眠状态，并在皮肤上做三个小洞。然后我实际上不会将任何器械放入膝关节内部。相反，布鲁斯播放了一段视频。我有一段以前对患者做过的真实关节镜检查的录像带，我会把它放进
in the VCR machine. We would tape all of these surgeries during this time and I would actually pretend like I was doing with the leg, what I would normally do if I was doing those different things during the real surgery. If I put something in the knee on the videotape, I would actually ask for that instrument and pretend like I was doing something. I'd move the leg around, I would splash water, we would ask and pass instruments like we were doing the real thing, even though we weren't doing any real surgery.
VCR录像机里。在这期间，我们会录下所有这些手术，我实际上会假装我对腿做着我平时在真实手术中做那些不同事情时的动作。如果我在录像带里把什么东西放进膝盖，我实际上会要求那个器械并假装我在做什么。我会移动腿，我会泼水，我们会像做真的一样要求和传递器械，尽管我们并没有做任何真实的手术。
Bruce took these additional measures because he wanted to account for situations where a patient was in 100% out from the anesthesia. The other thing about that videotape was it made certain that we spent the proper where a patient was in 100% out from the anesthesia. The other thing about that videotape was it made certain that we spent the proper amount of time under anesthesia. And for instance, we didn't want the placebo group where we didn't really do anything to be much shorter than the other types of surgeries so that if I went and talked to the nurses in the recovery room or the patients family afterwards, that they could look at their watch and say, oh, that was only 10 minutes, so it must have
布鲁斯采取这些额外的措施是因为他想考虑到患者从麻醉中100%清醒过来的情况。关于那段录像带的另一件事是，它确保我们在麻醉状态下度过了合适的时间。例如，我们不希望我们什么也没真正做的安慰剂组比其他类型的手术时间短得多，这样如果我随后去和恢复室的护士或患者家属交谈，他们可以看一眼手表然后说：“哦，那只用了10分钟，所以它一定
been a placebo. So we spent the same amount of time with the placebo group pretending to do surgery as if we had done the real surgery in the other groups. In all, 180 patients, mostly men, took part in the study. Bruce followed up with them a few times over the course of two years. The results were jaw dropping. Yes, I'd say jaw dropping was probably
是安慰剂。”因此，我们花了和在其他组做真实手术一样多的时间与假装做手术的安慰剂组在一起。总共有180名患者（主要是男性）参与了这项研究。布鲁斯在两年内对他们进行数次随访。结果令人大跌眼镜。是的，我会说大跌眼镜可能是
one of the best ways to describe it. Patients in all three groups had similar functioning in their knees. All three groups basically were the same. All three groups felt they were better off for having had the surgery that they'd recommend it to family and friends. They'd do it again if they had it to do all over again. And so the conclusion was that all the benefit of
描述它的最好方式之一。三组患者的膝盖功能相似。这三组基本上是一样的。这三组都觉得因为做了这个手术而变得更好，他们会向家人和朋友推荐它。如果让他们从头再来一次，他们还会这样做。因此，结论是，
arthroscopic surgery to treat arthritic knees was from a placebo effect. To Bruce, the implications were clear. We shouldn't be doing arthroscopic surgery to treat arthritic knees, and the reason is because number one, it's invasive. When you do go to sleep, and there is risk, and although the complication rate is very low, the chance of bad things happening is pretty low. It's not zero. And so, God forbid that you ever put somebody to sleep and did a surgery on them entirely for a pretend surgery effect.
关节镜手术治疗关节炎膝盖的所有益处都来自于安慰剂效应。对布鲁斯来说，其含义显而易见。我们不应该做关节镜手术来治疗关节炎膝盖，原因在于，第一，它是侵入性的。当你进入睡眠状态时，是存在风险的，尽管并发症发生率非常低，但发生坏事的几率相当低。并非为零。因此，但愿你永远不要让任何人入睡并纯粹为了假手术效果而对他们进行手术。
And they had a heart attack or a stroke or any number of other things. And you would really regret under those circumstances ever having done that. Then there's the money. If you do arthroscopic knee surgery, which currently is the most commonly performed orthopedic surgery worldwide today, and you're doing it all for a placebo benefit, it's going to run into the millions, probably billions of dollars of cost. If patients are benefiting from the surgery because they're experiencing the placebo effect, Bruce says we should find other, more effective treatments and put our money there.
而他们却心脏病发作、中风或发生其他各种事情。在这种情况下，你真的会后悔曾经这样做过。然后是金钱。如果你做了关节镜膝关节手术，它目前是全球最常进行的骨科手术，而你做这一切全是为了安慰剂效益，这将花费数百万，甚至可能是数十亿美元的成本。如果患者从手术中受益是因为他们经历了安慰剂效应，布鲁斯说我们应该寻找其他更有效的治疗方法，并把资金投在那里。
To be clear, he doesn't want to suggest that this surgery is ineffective across the board. This is not an indictment of arthroscopic surgery. I use arthroscopic surgery all the time to treat all kinds of things, just not arthritis. And it's not an indictment of surgery to treat arthritis. We have really effective treatments for severe arthritis, it's called a knee replacement. Brusa study was published in the New England Journal of Medicine in 2002. Plenty of people appreciated having an evaluation of this widely used procedure. But many of Brusa's fellow orthopedic surgeons were not pleased.
需要明确的是，他并不是想暗示这种手术在各个方面都无效。这不是对关节镜手术的指责。我一直使用关节镜手术来治疗各种各样的问题，只是不治疗关节炎。这也不是对治疗关节炎手术的指责。我们有非常有效的治疗严重关节炎的方法，它被称为膝关节置换术。布鲁斯的研究于2002年发表在《新英格兰医学杂志》上。许多人很感激能对这种广泛使用的程序进行评估。但布鲁斯的许多同行骨科医生并不高兴。
Oh my gosh, the vitriol that came out at the different meetings where we presented, and then if you're a surgeon, and you were routinely performing arthroscopic surgery for arthritic knees, and your patients were routinely telling you that they were better, you would like to thank it's due to your surgical skill. And what my study showed, or I should say our study showed, is that it wasn't due to their surgical skill. It was due to the placebo effect, and the fact that patients were going to sleep and believing
天哪，在我们发表研究的不同会议上出现的尖酸刻薄的言论，然后如果你是一名外科医生，并且你经常为关节炎膝盖实施关节镜手术，而你的患者经常告诉你他们变好了，你会认为是由于你的外科手术技能。而我的研究所显示的——或者我应该说我们的研究所显示的——是，这并不是由于他们的外科手术技能。这是由于安慰剂效应，以及患者进入睡眠并相信
that they're having something done that would make their knees better. Orthopedic surgeons eventually came around. Because of Bruce's study and later trials by other researchers, the American Academy of Orthopedic Surgeons does not recommend near-throscopy in patients with arthritis. In the Yersen's Brusa study was published,
他们正在接受能让膝盖变好的治疗这一事实。骨科医生最终改变了看法。由于布鲁斯的研究以及其他研究人员后来的试验，美国骨科医师学会不建议对患有关节炎的患者进行膝关节镜检查。在布鲁斯的研究发表后的几年里，
other researchers have run placebo-controlled surgery studies. They've covered a range of pain-related and chronic conditions from back pain to obesity. In 2015, Bruce looked at the results. Realt surgery did help lots of patients, but Bruce also found that substantial numbers of patients got better with placebo surgeries. In the case of pain, improvements from placebo surgeries were almost the case of pain, improvements from placebo surgeries were almost the same as the improvements were from real surgeries. For Bruce, these results have led them to think about surgery in a new way.
其他研究人员进行了安慰剂对照手术研究。他们涵盖了一系列与疼痛相关的慢性疾病，从背痛到肥胖。2015年，布鲁斯查看了结果。真实的手术确实帮助了许多患者，但布鲁斯也发现相当多的患者通过安慰剂手术得到了好转。在疼痛的情况下，安慰剂手术带来的改善几乎与真实手术带来的改善
Well, it certainly makes you stop and take pause whenever we're doing a surgery purely for pain relief because from what I know now, just the act of bringing somebody to an operating room, having them go to sleep in this fairly dramatic environment, doing some kind of procedure and having them wake up and go home and then go through a recovery. All of that fuels this very strong emotional and psychological belief on the part of the patient that their pain is going to get better or their shoulder is going to get better, pain is going to get better or their shoulders is going to get better, knees are going to get better, whatever. So, it certainly makes you take notice of that.
几乎相同。对布鲁斯来说，这些结果促使他以一种新的方式思考手术。嗯，这当然会让你停下来并三思，每当我们纯粹为了缓解疼痛而做手术时，因为据我所知，仅仅是把某人带进手术室，让他们在这个相当戏剧化的环境中入睡，做某种手术，然后让他们醒来回家并经历恢复。所有这一切都在患者心中激发了一种非常强烈的、情感和心理上的信念，即他们的疼痛会好转，或者他们的肩膀会好转，疼痛会好转或者肩膀会好转，膝盖会好转，无论如何。所以，这当然会引起你对这一点的注意。
But if Bruce has come to feel less confident about the power of some surgeries to heal, he has come to feel more confident about using a power that he previously undervalued. He's realized that the treatment he offers patients isn't just about what he can do in the operating theater. It's about what comes before, what comes after. Well, I think every time I come out of surgery and go talk to a family, there are aspects of every surgery where you could probably say, I wish I'd done this better, or this could have happened a little more efficiently. And most of its subtlety nuance,
但如果布鲁斯对某些手术治愈的力量变得不那么自信，他对自己以前低估的一种力量则变得更加自信。他意识到他提供给患者的治疗不仅仅关于他在手术室里能做什么。它关乎之前发生的事，之后发生的事。嗯，我认为每次我从手术室出来去和家属交谈时，每场手术中都有一些方面你可能会说：“我希望我把这做得更好，或者这个可以更有效率一点。”其中大部分是微妙的细微差别，
it probably doesn't have anything to do with the ultimate outcome. But I always emphasize the positives, when I go talk to the family that is, I share with them all the things that I'm extremely happy about. And I think by emphasizing those things rather than any kind of negatives, the patient's
它可能与最终结果没有任何关系。但我总是强调积极的一面，也就是说当我跟家属交谈时，我与他们分享我感到极其高兴的所有事情。而且我认为通过强调这些而不是任何负面情况，患者的
family gets a good feeling about it, they share those feelings with the patient. We emphasize with the patient when they come back to see me in the office the same things. And so I think all of that, you're going to harness the benefit of the placebo effect by fueling into their belief that the surgery or the procedure is going to help them be better. All of this, of course, raises tricky, ethical and philosophical questions. Should doctors prioritize honesty with their patients about everything else? Or should they prioritize healing? Even if that occasionally involves deception.
家属就会对它产生一种很好的感觉，他们会与患者分享这些感受。当患者回到办公室看我时，我们也会向患者强调同样的事情。因此我认为这一切，你将通过激发他们对手术或治疗会帮助他们变好的信念，来利用安慰剂效应的好处。所有这一切，当然引发了棘手的伦理和哲学问题。医生是否应该在所有其他事情上优先考虑对患者的诚实？还是他们应该优先考虑疗愈？即使这偶尔涉及欺骗。
In 1778, an Austrian physician named Anton Mesmer arrived in Paris. He set up a salon to treat patients. He wanted to heal people, but his treatments involved much more flair and drama than you'd find in most doctors' offices. For one thing, he wore a distinctive outfit. Mesmer would wear a special purple robe that seemed to be designed to associate him with the signs of the zodiac and astrological power. This is Emily Ogden. She is the author of her book about Anton Mesmer and his followers. She's also a professor of English at the University of Virginia. Anton Mesmer's purple robe was a hint of the theatrics that would come. He'd gather
1778年，一位名叫安东·梅斯默的奥地利医生抵达巴黎。他设立了一个沙龙来治疗患者。他想治愈人们，但他的治疗涉及比你在大多数医生办公室里看到的更多的气场和戏剧性。首先，他穿着一套独特的服装。梅斯默会穿一件特别的紫色长袍，这似乎旨在将他与十二星座的标志和占星术的力量联系起来。这是埃米利·奥格登。她是关于安东·梅斯默及其追随者的书的作者。她也是弗吉尼亚大学的英语教授。安东·梅斯默的紫色长袍暗示了即将上演的戏剧性。他会把
patients in a room decorated with celestial symbols, with glass harmonica music filling the air. In the middle of the room, there was a device that he called the Bake. Think of a hot tub except shorter with a lid on top. Inside the backe, there was water and broken glass. And then rods would protrude out of it. A group of patients who suffered from a range of physical and psychological maladies sat around the backe. And you would have each one of them touch one of these metal
患者聚集在一个装饰着天体符号的房间里，玻璃口琴音乐充斥着空气。房间正中央有一个他称之为“木桶浴”的装置。想象一下一个较短的带有盖子的热水浴缸。木桶浴里面有水和碎玻璃。然后会有杆子从里面伸出来。一群患有各种身体和心理疾病的患者坐在木桶浴周围。你会让他们每个人都触摸这些金属
rods. And he gathered around them a rope, which connect all of the patients to each other. Anton Mesmer and his assistants performed a choreographed set of gestures with the patients. They would touch their diaphragms and their stomachs, they would wave iron wands over them. The iron rods were supposed to remove the obstructions in the body that cause disease. What happened to these patients after these gestures is part of what made Anton Mesmer famous and infamous. Some of them would become drowsy, others would become agitated, some would start to cough and especially cough up fluid,
杆中的一个。他在他们周围围了一根绳子，将所有的患者彼此连接起来。安东·梅斯默和他的助手们对患者进行了一套编排好的手势。他们会触摸他们的横膈膜和胃，他们会在他们身上挥舞铁魔杖。铁棒本应消除体内导致疾病的阻塞。在这些手势之后这些患者身上发生了什么，正是让安东·梅斯默成名又声名狼藉的部分原因。他们中的一些人会变得昏昏欲睡，另一些人会变得焦躁不安，一些人会开始咳嗽，特别是咳出液体，
which was not unexpected in the context of signs of illness and humoral medicine at the time. And then some of them would undergo some really dramatic effects like convulsions, and what seemed to happen, according at least to some of the observers, is that patients would convulse, and then that convulsion would spread throughout the room.
在当时疾病体征和体液医学的背景下，这并不出乎意料。然后他们中的一些人会经历一些非常戏剧性的反应，比如抽搐，而根据至少一些观察者的说法，似乎发生的情况是患者会抽搐，然后这种抽搐会在房间里蔓延开来。
So it turned into a kind of a pandemonium of symptoms of convulsions, but then also mesmerclaimed of cures. Some patients, in fact, did get better. Anton Mesmer had a theory to explain what was going on. He thought that there was a fluid called animal magnetism that permeated the cosmos, but that was particularly active in human nerves, and he thought that through gestures and the use of special instruments, you could control the fluid, and that by controlling it, you
所以它变成了一种抽搐症状的狂热，但梅斯默也声称治愈了。事实上，有些患者确实好转了。安东·梅斯默有一个理论来解释正在发生的事情。他认为有一种名为动物磁性的流体渗透了宇宙，但在人类神经中特别活跃，他认为通过手势和特殊仪器的使用，你可以控制这种流体，并且通过控制它，你
could cure a wide range of diseases, especially diseases that were thought of at the time as nervous diseases. The physician had influential followers, like the French aristocrat, the Marquit de Lafayette. Lafayette toured the United States to spread word about animal magnetisms, miraculous powers. If you're thinking, this is bonkers, this Mesmer Guy is a fraud, while you and Ben Franklin have something in common. Yes, that Ben Franklin. He was appointed by the King of France to lead a commission to investigate Mesmer.
可以治愈广泛的疾病，特别是当时被认为是神经系统疾病的疾病。这位医生拥有很有影响力的追随者，比如法国贵族拉斐特侯爵。拉斐特巡游美国以宣扬动物磁性的神奇力量。如果你在想，这太疯狂了，这个梅斯默是个骗子，那么你和本·富兰克林有共同点。是的，就是那个本·富兰克林。他被法国国王任命领导一个委员会来调查梅斯默。
The commission ran experiments to see if patients were getting better because of animal magnetism or something else. These tests were groundbreaking. They were the first known experiments that involved what we'd now call a placebo control. Which means that they made people believe that they were magnetizing them when they were not magnetizing them and also conversely they magnetized patients without their knowledge. The results of the experiments did exactly what Anton Messmer's critics had hoped. They made him look like a fraud. They had one woman who was known to be magnetically susceptible and they brought her to a room.
该委员会进行了实验，以观察患者是因为动物磁性还是其他原因而好转。这些测试具有突破性。它们是已知最早涉及我们现在所称的安慰剂对照的实验。这意味着他们让人们相信他们正在对他们进行磁化，而实际上并没有这样做；反之亦然，他们在患者不知情的情况下对他们进行了磁化。实验结果完全符合安东·梅斯默的批评者们的期望。这让他看起来像个骗子。他们有一名众所周知具有磁敏感性的女性，他们把她带到一个房间里。
They blindfolded her and they had one of the members of the commission pretend to magnetize her, but in fact he was doing nothing at all. And she, without any magnetization after a certain period of time, went into an elaborate magnetic crisis. They did the reverse too. In one test, an investigator stood behind a panel and
他们蒙上她的眼睛，让委员会的一名成员假装磁化她，但实际上他什么也没做。而她在没有进行任何磁化的一段时间后，陷入了复杂的磁性危机中。他们也做了相反的测试。在一次测试中，一名调查员站在一块面板后面，
waived iron rods at a patient who couldn't see what was happening. She showed no effects whatsoever, although he magnetized her vigorously for some time. And so what the commissioners believed they had shown here was that the effects that Mesmer was eliciting had to do with patient belief and with the bond between the patient and the Mesmerizer and not with the animal magnetic fluid. The members of the commission believed they had humiliated Anton Mesmer. A future president of the United States made a prediction after the report came out. John Adams said it would annihilate the enthusiasm for mesmerism. The debunking of Anton Mesmer, however, itself fell victim to a falsehood. Investigators
对一个看不到发生了什么的患者挥舞铁棒。她没有表现出任何效果，尽管他一段时间来一直在大力磁化她。因此，委员们认为他们在此展示的是，梅斯默引出的效果与患者的信念以及患者与梅斯默施法者之间的纽带有关，而与动物磁液无关。委员会成员相信他们已经羞辱了安东·梅斯默。美国未来的一位总统在报告发布后做出了一个预测。约翰·亚当斯说，这将消灭对磁迷信的热情。然而，对安东·梅斯默的揭穿本身也沦为了谎言的牺牲品。调查人员
did show that mesmeric techniques were no better than a placebo. Critics concluded that mesmerism was worthless. But in fact, this was not true. Some of the investigators themselves noted that while mesmer's theory of animal magnetism was nonsense, many of his techniques worked. They certainly did think that mesmer's gestures, that mesmer's pressure on the stomach, that the excitement of the public treatment salon, they thought that all of those things had their effect. It was just that their effect didn't happen immediately through the communication of animal magnetism, but in effect directly by the drama acting on the imagination of the patient. When people said mesmerism was worthless, they were saying that only some kinds of cures were real cures. Cures created by drama didn't count.
确实表明，梅斯默的技术并不比安慰剂好多少。批评者得出结论，认为磁迷信毫无价值。但事实上，并非如此。一些调查人员自己指出，虽然梅斯默的动物磁性理论是一派胡言，但他的许多技术确实管用。他们确实认为梅斯默的手势、梅斯默对胃部的压力、公众治疗沙龙的兴奋感，他们认为所有这些事情都起到了作用。只是它们的作用不是通过动物磁性的传递立即发生的，而是通过戏剧直接作用于患者的想象力而产生的效果。当人们说磁迷信毫无价值时，他们是在说只有某种治愈才是真正的治愈。由戏剧创造的治愈不算数。
It seems like there's been a kind of an agreement in some of these conversations that in order for a cure to be real, it has to have a physical event associated with it, not a psychological event. What Mesma had really shown was that patients often get better not because of the doctor's skill and not because of the doctor's cure, but because of the very presence of the doctor. Ironically most physicians have shied away from the starring role. Only some, like Benjamin Rush, a respected doctor and one of the signers of the Declaration of Independence, understood the powerful tool that Anton Mesmer had inadvertently revealed.
似乎在其中一些对话中已经达成了一种共识，即为了让治愈是真实的，它必须伴随着一个物理事件，而不是心理事件。梅斯默真正显示的是，患者往往会好转，不是因为医生的技术，也不是因为医生的疗法，而是因为医生的切身存在。具有讽刺意味的是，大多数医生都避开了这个主演角色。只有少数人，比如备受尊敬的医生、《独立宣言》签署人之一本杰明·拉什，理解了安东·梅斯默无意中揭示的强大工具。
He said at the time that he deplored Mesmer's silly pretensions to cure by animal magnetism, but that he encouraged his medical students to avail themselves of the ability that the imagination had to cure. The dilemmas posed by this debate live on in our own time. Even today, centuries after Anton Mesmer produced convulsions in patients, most people in medicine do not believe their job is to harness their patients' imaginations. Ted Kaptchak is an exception. He believes the drama embedded in the doctor-patient relationship is deeply connected to healing.
他在当时表示，他痛恨梅斯默通过动物磁性治病的愚蠢伪装，但他鼓励他的医学生利用想象力治愈疾病的能力。这场辩论带来的困境在我们的时代依然存在。即使在今天，在安东·梅斯默引发患者抽搐几个世纪后，医学界的绝大多数人仍然不相信他们的工作是驾驭患者的想象力。泰德·卡普查克是个例外。他认为医患关系中内置的戏剧性与疗愈紧密相连。
It's a focus of his research. I'm a professor of medicine at Harvard Medical School, and I'm director of the program in placebo studies at the Beth Israel Deaconess Medical Center. In the 1970s, when he arrived in Cambridge, Massachusetts, he was about as far from the world of elite Western medicine as you could imagine. Ted is not a physician, he's an herbalist. He studied Chinese medicine in Macau, Taiwan, and China. He set up shop on a street in Cambridge with an unflattering reputation.
这是他研究的焦点。我是哈佛医学院的医学教授，也是贝斯以色列女执事医疗中心安慰剂研究项目的负责人。在20世纪70年代，当他来到马萨诸塞州剑桥市时，他距离精英西方医学的世界可以说是极其遥远。泰德不是医生，他是一名草药医师。他在中国澳门、台湾和大陆学习过中医。他在剑桥的一条名声不佳的街道上开了一家店。
I rent an apartment on Quack Row. I didn't know it was Quack Row, but there were lots of all kinds of healers on the street. There were all kinds of energy healers. There were past life. All the new age kind of stuff was on that block. Ted's office decor was not what you might call Boston Brahman. You know, an herbalist, so I had at least two, three hundred herbs and jars all over the waiting room and along the walls. I had really wonderful pictures of China and some of the herbs were animal parts and, you know, lizards and, uh, geckos and seahorses.
我租了一套位于庸医街的公寓。我不知道那是庸医街，但街上有各种各样的各类治疗师。有各种各样的能量治疗师。有前世治疗师。所有新时代的那种东西都在那个街区。泰德办公室的装饰可不是你能称之为波士顿婆罗门风格的东西。你知道的，作为一名草药医师，所以在候诊室和墙壁沿线，我至少有两三百个装有草药的罐子。我有一些非常棒的中国照片，其中一些草药是动物部件，你知道的，蜥蜴、壁虎和海马。
Ted got positive feedback from patients all the time. But there were moments that made Ted ask, why exactly what patients feeling better? I see people walk into my office, sit down with me for 15, 20 minutes, half hour, and sometimes I'd only write a prescription for herbs. And as they walked out, I saw them walking out with less pain, more bounce in their, and their gait, and their face was as were different when they left. And I said, Ted, you just changed that person.
泰德一直收到患者的积极反馈。但也有一些时刻让泰德发问：患者究竟感受到了什么才觉得好起来的？我看到人们走进我的办公室，跟我坐在一起15、20分钟、半小时，有时我甚至只开一张草药处方。当他们走出去时，我看到他们走出去时痛苦减少了，步伐更有弹性了，他们离开时的面部表情也不同了。然后我说，泰德，你刚刚改变了那个人。
That was not the herbs. TADD looked at traditional Chinese medical texts to help him make sense of these kinds of interactions. And I realized there was statements like the medicine should start working before the patient takes the herbs. I started realizing that something else was going on that was more than my herbs and acupuncture. Ted asked himself what was going through the minds of his patients when they walked through his clinic door. They had hope they'd made the effort to come see him.
那可不是草药的功劳。泰德查阅了传统的中医文献，以帮助自己理解这类互动。我意识到有这样的说法，比如药物应该在患者服用草药之前就开始起作用。我开始意识到正在发生一些事情，它不仅仅是我的草药和针灸。泰德问自己，当他的患者走进他诊所的门时，他们的脑子里在想什么。他们怀有希望，他们付出了努力来见他。
But many had seen several doctors before him and had been disappointed. So they come with those kinds of feelings and they go into a ritual that you know I asked them how they are. I start talking, they expect me to ask some questions. I usually ask questions I didn't expect to make sure they knew they were getting something different. And I listened, I would lean over when I thought the patient wanted me to be a little closer.
但许多人在他之前已经看过几位医生并且感到失望。所以他们带着那种感觉来到这里，并进入了一个你懂的仪式，我问他们近况如何。我开始说话，他们期望我问一些问题。我通常会问一些他们意料之外的问题，以确保他们知道自己正在得到一些不同的东西。我倾听，当我认为患者希望我离得近一点时，我会前倾。
I'd pull back when I saw the patient didn't want me to be closer. I would actually think and say, let me think for a minute, if I thought the patient needed to see me be attentive, I sometimes asked people to explain things better. I got to know something about them personally that was important so I can bring it up the next time. All those maneuvers in the context. That sounds like acting.
当我看到患者不希望我离得近时，我会后退。我实际上会思考并说：“让我想一分钟，”如果我认为患者需要看到我很专心的话，我有时会请人们把事情解释得更清楚。我了解了一些关于他们个人的重要事情，以便下次我可以提出来。在那种背景下的所有这些举措。这听起来像是在演戏。
Hey, it's a drama. Healing is a ritual in drama that everyone in the world knows, at least their cultural forms of it. That drama activates neurons and activates a neurological process that's involved with weak call now, biomedicine at this point, the placebo effect. You got it right on the head. at this point, the placebo effect. You got it right on the head. Ted was doing what Anton Mesmer was doing. He was using drama to unleash healing. This is where Ted's work on Quack Row at Harvard Medical School Connect. In 1990, Harvard recruited Ted to do research on alternative medicine.
嘿，这就是一出戏。疗愈是一种仪式和戏剧，世界上每个人都知道，至少有其文化形式。这种戏剧激活了神经元，并激活了一个神经学过程，这个过程与我们现在称之为生物医学的东西有关，即安慰剂效应。你完全说对了。这时，安慰剂效应。你完全说对了。泰德在做安东·梅斯默做过的事。他正在利用戏剧来释放疗愈。这就是泰德在庸医街的工作与哈佛医学院交汇的地方。1990年，哈佛招募泰德来做关于替代医学的研究。
The idea was, his experience practicing traditional Chinese medicine would give other researchers useful perspective. At first, Ted didn't feel at home amongst the MDs and PhDs. I felt like a reptile in a mammalian environment. I was like pre-scientific. Gradually, Ted became more comfortable with the techniques and norms of contemporary science. Harvard gave him research training and assigned him to some projects. They told me that your job Ted is to help us decide or discover or uncover whether any of
当时的理念是，他从事传统中医的经验将为其他研究人员提供有用的视角。起初，泰德在医学博士和哲学博士中间并没有宾至如归的感觉。我觉得自己就像哺乳动物环境中的一只爬行动物。我就像是前科学时代的。渐渐地，泰德对当代科学的技术和规范变得更加适应。哈佛为他提供了研究培训，并给他分配了一些项目。他们告诉我，泰德，你的工作是帮我们决定或发现或揭示这些替代疗法中是否有任何一种
these alternate treatments are more than a placebo effect. And I would ask my mentors, I said, so what is this placebo effect? And they said it's the effect of an inert substance. And I said, that's an oxymoron. And I said, you know what, I'm going to make a pivot. I'm going to study the placebo effect, not alternate medicine. It's hard to overstate just how unusual that was. In the 1990s, placebos were not a subject of study. They were a tool that pharmaceutical companies and medical researchers used to figure out whether a drug or treatment was effective.
不仅仅是安慰剂效应。我会问我的导师们，我说，那么这个安慰剂效应到底是什么？他们说这是一种惰性物质的效果。我说，那是一个矛盾修辞法。我说，你知道吗，我要转变方向了。我要研究安慰剂效应，而不是替代医学。很难夸大那是多么不同寻常。在20世纪90年代，安慰剂不是研究的主题。它们是制药公司和医学研究人员用来弄清楚某种药物或治疗是否有效的工具。
If people get better, we want to know if it's because the drug we gave them, or is it spontaneous remission, or is it because of the Dr. Patient interaction? Is it because of the ritual of taking pills? Bio-medicine is really, is very interested in whether a drug has a specific target that works independent of all those other factors. That's where the placebo control comes in. It's a way of making medicine more like science and more scientific. And it is. The problem is, this can lead to the same kind of logic we heard from the people who debunked
如果人们好转了，我们想知道是因为我们给他们的药物，还是自愈，还是因为医患互动？是因为吃药的仪式吗？生物医学真的很关注某种药物是否有独立于所有其他因素之外起作用的具体靶点。这就是安慰剂对照发挥作用的地方。这是一种让医学更像科学、更具科学性的方法。确实如此。问题在于，这可能会导致我们从那些揭穿了
Anton Mesmer. If a drug improves patients' pain by 70%, and a placebo improves it by 70%, research us don't stop and say, wait, sugar pills are alleviating 70% of the pain. They say, this drug doesn't work. In other words, cures don't count as cures when they are caused by placebos. It totally dismisses what happens
安东·梅斯默。如果某种药物能将患者的疼痛减轻70%，而安慰剂也能将其减轻70%，研究人员不会停下来惊叹，等等，糖丸居然能缓解70%的疼痛。他们会换个说法，这种药物没有用。换句话说，当治愈效果是由安慰剂引起时，它们就不算真正的治愈。这完全抹杀了在
in the placebo arm of a randomized controlled trial. It says, well, this drug is no good, it's no better than the placebo, where this drug is really good, it's better than placebo. Rather than dismiss the placebo effect as merely what happens in the control arm of a trial, Ted decided he would study the placebo in its own right.
随机对照试验的安慰剂组中发生的一切。这种观点认为，这个药物不行，它并不比安慰剂好，或者说这个药物真的很棒，它比安慰剂更好。特德决定不把安慰剂效应仅仅视为试验对照组中发生的一幕，而是要对安慰剂本身进行研究。
In 2008, he published a study on treatments for irritable bowel syndrome or IBS. 262 patients were randomly assigned to one of three groups. All the patients were screened by a doctor. The first group was told to keep doing what they had been previously doing. The idea was to see if patients got better merely through the passage of time. Think of this as the time heals arm of the study. The second group was assigned to a pretend treatment involving acupuncture needles.
2008年，他发表了一项关于肠易激综合征（简称IBS）治疗的研究。262名患者被随机分配到三个组别中的一组。所有患者都经过医生的筛查。第一组被告知继续做他们之前一直在做的事情。这个设想是为了观察患者是否仅仅通过时间的流逝而好转。你可以把这看作是研究中的“时间治愈”组。第二组则被分配接受一种涉及针灸针的假治疗。
The last group got the pretend treatment plus a bonus. They also had a warm empathetic conversation with the acupuncturist who was trained to ask them a number of questions. Why they thought they had dealness, what made it better, we asked them how was the effect their work, how to fix their lives, and we did things like touch, attentive listening, we asked them to repeat where it's explained us what it meant. Ted also gave the acupuncturist, acting advice. Ask the patient if you can be still for 20 seconds and think about them, and then ask them
最后一组接受了假治疗外加额外福利。他们与针灸师进行了温暖而富有同理心的对话，针灸师受过培训，会向他们提出许多问题。比如他们认为自己为什么会生病、是什么让病情好转、我们询问这对他们的工作有什么影响、如何修复他们的生活，我们还做了一些事情，比如触碰、专心倾听，我们让他们重复解释这些话意味着什么。特德还给这位针灸师提出了表演建议。询问患者是否可以保持安静20秒并思考他们，然后向他们
an important question that they would want to hear. What Ted and his colleagues did with the study was to break down the placebo effect into three components. Each arm built on the other. One, time heals. Two, time heals plus a pretend treatment. Three, time heals plus a pretend treatment plus warm interactions with a health care provider. And we got really a very straight line.
提出一个他们渴望听到的重要问题。特德和他的同事在这项研究中所做的是将安慰剂效应拆解为三个组成部分。每一个组别都在前一个的基础上构建。第一，时间治愈。第二，时间治愈加上假治疗。第三，时间治愈加上假治疗，再加上与医护人员的温暖互动。我们最终得到了非常清晰的线性结果。
We had a small placebo effect with no treatment because time heals. We had a moderate placebo effect with just a fake treatment. And then we did the full Monty. It went up to 60% improvement to adequate relief. That's an incredible amount of placebo effect. Tatted shown that the placebo effect could be valuable in its own right as a treatment. His study demonstrated that the placebo effect was made up of different factors, each of which could be deliberately employed to unleash healing.
在没有治疗的情况下，由于时间治愈，我们看到了微弱的安慰剂效应。仅凭假治疗，我们看到了中度的安慰剂效应。然后我们拿出了全套方案。对充分缓解的改善率上升到了60%。这带来了惊人的安慰剂效应。特德证明了安慰剂效应作为一种治疗手段本身就极具价值。他的研究表明，安慰剂效应由不同的因素构成，每一个因素都可以被刻意利用来激发身体的治愈能力。
But Ted also recognized that placebo's demanded something that made doctors uncomfortable. Deception. Everyone believed that deception or concealment is necessary for people to respond to placebo because the idea was well you fake people you tricked them. Placebo is kind of this trickery and I sat with myself for a long time read the literature and I said you know what no one's tested that ever in history. What's going on here? When we come back, is deception necessary for the placebo effect to work? Can honesty and the placebo effect mix?
但特德也意识到，安慰剂需要一种让医生感到不舒服的东西。欺骗。每个人都认为欺骗或隐瞒是人们对安慰剂产生反应的必要条件，因为人们的想法是，好吧，你欺骗了大家，你把他们耍了。安慰剂有点像这种骗局，我在那里坐了很长时间，阅读了相关文献，然后我说，你知道吗，历史上从来没有人测试过这一点。这到底是怎么回事？我们回来后将探讨：欺骗是安慰剂效应发挥作用的必要条件吗？诚实能与安慰剂效应结合吗？
I find this just as astonishing as anybody else, and I'm the patient here. There's something about sitting in a chair at a hair salon that makes people talk. It feels safe to discuss personal things. When clients have a cape draped around their necks and wisps of hair are falling to the floor, they gab. Oh yeah, they tell you all their problems or troubles and the good stuff, the bad stuff, yeah. This is Linda Bonano. She's been a hairdresser in Northern Massachusetts for decades. Linda realized that people often walk out of her salon with the feeling of ease. She thinks it's because she's a good listener. Linda realized that people often walk out of her salon with the feeling of ease.
我和其他人一样觉得这不可思议，而我正是这里的患者。坐在美发沙龙的椅子上，总有某种魔力让人打开话匣子。讨论私事让人感到安全。当客户的脖子上披着斗篷，几缕碎发落在地板上时，他们就开始闲聊了。哦，是的，他们会向你倾诉所有的烦恼、麻烦，还有美好的事、糟糕的事，是的。这是琳达·博纳诺。几十年来，她一直是马萨诸塞州北部的一名美发师。琳达意识到，人们离开她的沙龙时往往会有一种轻松感。她认为这是因为她是一个很好的倾听者。琳达意识到，人们离开她的沙龙时往往会有一种轻松感。
She thinks it's because she's a good listener. How would you be able to tell when someone felt better after they had talked with you? Would you look for signs to sort of know that they were happy? You could see, they have a smile on their face, their personality changes, their attitude changes, tone of their voice. Linda has also seen what such interactions look like from the opposite perspective, as someone who confides in others. That's because for many years, she's had to seek out medical care for a debilitating condition. I ended up with severe diarrhea and intestinal pains running to the bathroom all the time.
她认为这是因为她是一个很好的倾听者。当别人和你倾诉后感觉好些了，你是怎么看出来的呢？你会寻找什么样的迹象来大致知道他们是高兴的吗？你可以看到，他们脸上带着微笑，他们的个性变了，他们的态度变了，说话的语调也变了。琳达也从相反的角度——作为一个向他人倾诉的人——经历过这种互动。那是因为多年来，她不得不因一种使人虚弱的疾病去寻求医疗护理。我最终得了严重的腹泻和肠痛，不得不一直跑厕所。
Sometimes, the pains would come like every half an hour. I couldn't even move. It was worse than labor pains. You're better off having a baby than what I went through. It was very, very severe. The pain and diarrhea interfered with every part of Linda's life. She had to skip meals before social events. She got used to leaving gatherings early. She couldn't get work done. I used to run machinery. I worked for a medical company. And I remember one time I was came in over and paying.
有时候，疼痛每半个小时就会发作一次。我甚至无法动弹。这比分娩的阵痛还要糟糕。生孩子也比我经历的要好受得多。病情非常非常严重。疼痛和腹泻干扰了琳达生活的方方面面。她在社交活动前不得不不吃东西。她习惯了提前离开聚会。她无法完成工作。我过去常常操作机器。我在一家医疗公司工作。我记得有一次我忍着疼痛去上班。
I went, oh, how am I going to run this machine? I figured I'd better go home. My boss wouldn't let me leave early. I had to wait till 7 o'clock. And I'm thinking, how am I going to run this machine? So thank God my buddies there. They know what I go through. They said, Linda, sit down.
我当时想，天哪，我该怎么操作这台机器？我想我最好还是回家吧。我的老板不让我提前离开。我不得不一直等到7点钟。我在想，我该怎么操作这台机器？谢天谢地，我的好朋友们都在那儿。他们知道我经历了什么。他们说，琳达，坐下吧。
Don't worry about it. We'll take care of it for you until 7 o'clock comes, and then you can leave. But the thing is, the episode makes me drag at least two days. I can't go to work. I can't do anything. A doctor told her she was lactose intolerant. She cut out dairy, but it didn't help. She continued to organize her life around the inevitability
别担心。我们帮你把机器照看好，直到7点钟到来，然后你就可以走人了。但关键是，每次发作都会让我萎靡不振至少两天。我没法上班。我什么也做不了。一位医生告诉她，她患有乳糖不耐症。她戒掉了乳制品，但这并没有什么帮助。她继续围绕着不可避免的
of pain. Linda had been suffering for a decade when an opportunity appeared on TV. It was like a commercial. The advertising came on and my eyes spurt. I went, oh, what's this? A nearby hospital was conducting a study on patients with intestinal problems. Linda wasn't sure she'd be a good fit, but she figured, hey, you never know. She made an appointment and took some tests. It turned out, she was a good fit.
疼痛来安排自己的生活。琳达已经痛苦了十年，直到电视上出现了一个机会。就像一个商业广告。广告播出了，我的眼睛一下子亮了。我心想，哦，这是什么？附近的一家医院正在对患有肠道问题的患者进行一项研究。琳达不确定自己是否合适，但她想，嘿，不试试怎么知道。她预约并做了一些检查。结果证明，她很合适。
She was diagnosed with irritable bowel syndrome or IBS. A physician gave Linda capsules to take twice a day. But then he told Linda something that dashed her hopes. The capsule she was about to take, they were a placebo. Oh, I was disappointed. I knew it was a sugar pill. Because I graduated from Heser College as a medical assistant. So I knew a placebo was a sugar pill. And I thought, he made me come all the way down here
她被诊断患有肠易激综合征，也就是IBS。一位医生给了琳达每天服用两次的胶囊。但接着，医生对琳达说的一番话打破了她的希望。她即将服用的胶囊是安慰剂。哦，我很失望。我知道那是糖丸。因为我毕业于赫瑟学院，是一名医疗助理。所以我知道安慰剂就是糖丸。我心想，他让我大老远跑来这里
to take a sugar pill. I thought to myself, why is he doing this? Why tell Linda she was getting a placebo? Wouldn't that undermine the effect of the sugar pill? Well, that's what the study was supposed to test. Could a placebo help patients if they knew it was a placebo? The study had 80 patients and was being run by Ted Capchak. It was an open-label placebo trial. Instead of deception, patients would receive what Ted is called radical honesty. The study was based on an insight.
就是为了吃一颗糖丸？我心想，他为什么要这么做？为什么要告诉琳达她吃的是安慰剂？这难道不会削弱糖丸的效果吗？嗯，这正是该研究要测试的内容。如果患者知道那是安慰剂，安慰剂还能帮助他们吗？这项研究有80名患者，由特德·卡普查克负责。这是一项开放标签的安慰剂试验。患者受到的不是欺骗，而是特德所说的彻底的诚实。这项研究基于一个深刻的见解。
The placebo effect wasn't just about the pills. It was about an edifice of drama, rituals, and the trust between patients like Linda and their doctors. Even though Linda was disappointed to get a placebo, she followed her doctor's orders. I just took them and went about my day. I said this is not going to work if it's a sugar pill. And it wasn't till the fourth day. I realized that it wasn't sick anymore. I said this can't be. I wasn't until the fourth day. I realized I wasn't sick anymore. I said, this can't be. Starting on that fourth day, the pain that Linda had suffered through for a decade vanished. For three weeks, I felt fantastic. I had no IBS. I wasn't sick. I was taking those pills every day and I couldn't believe it. Many other patients in the study got similar relief. Volunteers who received the Open Label placebo reported twice the improvement in their quality
安慰剂效应不仅仅关于药丸。它关乎由戏剧性、仪式感以及像琳达这样的患者与医生之间的信任共同构成的宏伟大厦。尽管琳达对拿到安慰剂感到失望，但她还是遵从了医生的医嘱。我只是把药吃了，然后继续过我的一天。我说如果这是糖丸，那肯定没用。直到第四天。我意识到我不再生病了。我说这不可能。我直到第四天。我意识到我不再生病了。我说，这不可能。从第四天开始，琳达痛苦了十年的疼痛消失了。有三个星期，我感觉好极了。我没有IBS。我没有生病。我每天都在吃那些药，我简直不敢相信。研究中的许多其他患者也得到了类似的缓解。接受开放标签安慰剂的志愿者报告称，他们的生活质量
of life as those who received no treatment. Now, this was a small study, but Ted has looked at the effects of using Open Label placebo's for other medical conditions. He's found similar, sometimes even better results, for low back pain and cancer-related fatigue. Placemos administered with radical honesty have the potential to help people. We turned the apple cart over on placemos studies. We said that everything we were saying about placebo before was actually not true, and it's probably more that's not true. After being on the placebo for three weeks, Linda went back to her doctor. She told him how great she felt.
得到了两倍于未接受治疗者的改善。这是一个小规模的研究，但特德已经研究了将开放标签安慰剂用于其他健康状况的效果。他发现对于下腰痛和癌症相关的疲劳，也有类似、有时甚至更好的结果。以彻底的诚实施用的安慰剂有可能帮助人们。我们彻底颠覆了安慰剂研究的陈规。我们说，以前关于安慰剂的所有说法其实都不是真的，而且可能还有更多说法也是假的。服用安慰剂三周后，琳达回到了她的医生那里。她告诉医生她感觉有多好。
She wanted to keep taking the pills, but the doctor said no. The study protocol only permitted patients to get placebo during the study. He said, no, no, no, we can't let you keep them. I said, what? I said, what am I supposed to do now? He says, well, you'll be fine. And I thought, well, I'm thinking, I'm not going to be fine. I know I'm not going to.
她想继续吃药，但医生说不行。研究方案只允许患者在研究期间服用安慰剂。他说，不，不，不，我们不能让你继续留着它们。我说，什么？我说，那我现在的日子该怎么过？他说，噢，你会好起来的。我想，嗯，我在想，我才不会好起来呢。我很清楚我不会好的。
Linda tried to be optimistic. The first few days, she didn't feel pain, so she thought the pills might have gotten rid of her IBS. But on the fourth day, the pain came back. Linda returned to her old ways of coping, taking anti-diarrhea drugs, restricting her diet, staying away from social activities. It went on for years. Finally, Linda reached out to Ted Capchak. He agreed to take her on as a patient, and he offered to put her on a placebo once again. And then I thought, well, that would be great. But then, her mind quickly jumped to concern.
琳达试图保持乐观。头几天，她没有感到疼痛，所以她认为这些药可能已经治好了她的IBS。但在第四天，疼痛又回来了。琳达回到了她以前的应对方式：服用止泻药、限制饮食、远离社交活动。这种情况持续了多年。最后，琳达联系了特德·卡普查克。他同意将她收治为患者，并提出再次让她服用安慰剂。然后我想，嗯，那太棒了。但是随即，她的脑海中迅速闪过担忧。
OK, it worked the last time if I take it again this time, is it going to work? I thought maybe it's not going to do anything second time around. And then I would have been even more disappointed. Despite her concerns, she decided to try the placebo again. Because when you're really sick with IBS, you will do and try anything. Anything to get rid of the pain and get back to normal. I did whatever these doctors told me to do and thank God I did because when I went back with Dr. Capchak and he put me back on the placepils it didn't even take a week and everything was gone again and I'm I'm I still when I think
好吧，上一次管用，如果这次再吃一次，还会管用吗？我想也许第二次什么作用也没有了。那我会更加失望的。尽管有所担忧，她还是决定再次尝试安慰剂。因为当你被IBS折磨得痛苦不堪时，你愿意做任何事、尝试任何方法。任何能摆脱痛苦并恢复正常生活的方法都可以。我照着这些医生吩咐我的任何事情去做，谢天谢地我这样做了，因为当我回到卡普查克医生那里，他让我重新吃回安慰剂时，甚至不到一个星期，所有的症状就又都消失了，我至今——每当我想起这件事，我依然感到震惊。
about it I'm stunned. I don't understand it I don't I met a point tell you the truth I don't understand it. I'm at a point to tell you the truth. I don't even care anymore. I just wanted to disappear and that's it. Even if Linda didn't fully understand what happened, she has some guesses about what relieved her pain. One vital factor, her deep faith, in Ted Kaptchak. He has a lot of patience, he's extremely intelligent, something about his personality, very calming.
我不理解，我真的不理解。说实话，我已经无所谓了。我甚至都不在乎了。我只希望它消失，就这样。即使琳达并不完全理解发生了什么，但对于是什么缓解了她的疼痛，她有一些猜测。一个至关重要的因素，是她对特德·卡普查克有着深深的信任。他非常有耐心，极其聪明，他的性格中有一种非常令人平静的特质。
When you talk to him, you feel like you had a complete body massage. Contrast this with her impersonal interaction with a doctor who diagnosed her with lactose intolerance. He was a kind of doctor just like a patient at the deli, you know what? Of course, there are still many things we don't know. We don't fully understand why Linda got better on the placebo and why she got worse when she stopped. We don't know how generalizable her experience is to others. Would we get less impressive results if
当你和他交谈时，你会感觉自己做了一场全身按摩。相比之下，她与那位诊断她患有乳糖不耐症的医生之间的冷漠互动简直天差地别。他那种医生就像是在熟食店排队买东西的顾客，你懂的？当然，仍有很多事情是我们不知道的。我们并不完全理解为什么琳达服用安慰剂后病情好转，以及为什么她停药后病情恶化。我们不知道她的经历对其他人有多大的普遍适用性。如果
placebo became a common treatment rather than a novel one? What if patients obtained placebo is from a pharmacy rather than from a kind doctor in a clinic? There's another problem. For some, the idea that placebo may be helpful is frustrating, even infuriating. In 2018, researchers from Northwestern University published a study showing that sugar pills can be effective in treating some patients who suffer from chronic pain. Some of the very patients who might benefit from that insight, people in chronic pain, took to Facebook to describe how demeaned they felt. One woman wrote, this is one of the worst
安慰剂成为一种常见的治疗方法，而不是一种新奇疗法，我们会得到不那么令人印象深刻的结果吗？如果患者是从药房而不是从诊所里那位亲切的医生那里获得安慰剂，会怎么样呢？这里还有另一个问题。对某些人来说，安慰剂可能有用的想法令人沮丧，甚至是激怒。2018年，西北大学的研究人员发表了一项研究，表明糖丸对治疗某些患有慢性疼痛的患者是有效的。其中一些本可以从这一见解中受益的患者，即那些处于慢性疼痛中的人，纷纷在Facebook上发帖，表达他们感到的受羞辱感。一位女性写道，这是对
insults to those with true chronic pain. This kind of pain is not all in their heads. They have real documented reasons to have moderate to severe pain and offering a placebo is unethical and a grave insult. Ted understands where such criticism is coming from. People think that if a placebo works, that means a patient was faking or that her suffering wasn't real, or that the pain was purely psychological. Ted says nothing could be further from the truth. The placebo effect is not a mind body, new age, mind cure. Those things happen not because you think, but because you do, you perform, and you enact. The placebo effect is embodied in what patients and doctors do.
真正的慢性疼痛患者最严重的侮辱之一。这种疼痛并非全凭臆想。他们有着真实且有据可查的理由去承受中度到重度的疼痛，而提供安慰剂是不道德的，也是一种严重的侮辱。特德理解这种批评来自何方。人们认为，如果安慰剂起作用了，那就意味着患者是在装病，或者她的痛苦不是真的，或者疼痛纯粹是心理上的。特德说，事实与此相去甚远。安慰剂效应不是一种身心合一的、新时代的、精神治愈法。这些事情的发生不是因为你想，而是因为你做了、你表现了、你演绎了。安慰剂效应体现在患者和医生的实际行动中。
It's way below and much stronger than thinking you're going to get better and you get better. Patients are the only ones who are skeptical of the placebo effect. Some researchers are as well. My name is Azbion Robyart son. I'm a professor at the University of Southern Denmark. Azbion has analyzed hundreds of placebo control studies. In general, he does not find a very strong placebo effect in most of the studies he reviewed. There is no indication based on the trials we looked at that there is a very large effective
它远比“你以为你会好起来，然后你就真的好起来了”这种想法要深远得多，也强大得多。不仅仅是患者对安慰剂效应持怀疑态度。一些研究人员也是如此。我叫阿斯比约恩·罗比阿特森。我是南丹麦大学的教授。阿斯比约恩分析了数百项安慰剂对照研究。总的来说，在他审查的大多数研究中，他并没有发现非常强烈的安慰剂效应。根据我们所研究的试验，没有任何迹象表明，在如此众多的各种病症中，
placebo on very many patients across very many conditions. That said, as beyond did find variations in the studies, and in some cases, he did find a large effect. The placebo effect was larger in conditions where patients reported their own outcomes, things like pain and nausea, and smaller in cases where doctors made measurements, things like hypertension. Aspion also found what Bruce mostly discovered in Houston. If a pill produces a small placebo effect, treatments that look and sound dramatic induce
安慰剂对非常多的患者产生了非常巨大的效果。话虽如此，阿斯比约恩确实在研究中发现了差异，在某些情况下，他确实发现了显著的效果。在患者自行报告结果的病症中，例如疼痛和恶心，安慰剂效应更大；而在医生进行测量的病症中，例如高血压，安慰剂效应则较小。阿斯比约恩还发现了布鲁斯在休斯顿大部分发现的规律。如果一粒药丸产生的安慰剂效应很小，那么看起来和听起来具有戏剧性的治疗方法就会诱发
bigger effects. We clearly see that the more theatrical or dramatic placebo goes with kind of the needling or with machines that make a sound, they tend to have larger effects. Most of the studies Aspirin looked at were testing the efficacy of various drugs. They just had a placebo arm. They were not designed to elicit the placebo effect in the way Ted Capchuck has done, they didn't focus on all the rituals around treatment. Aspion agrees that studies like those, what are sometimes called active placebo studies,
更大的效果。我们清楚地看到，更具戏剧性或表演性质的安慰剂，伴随着扎针或是发出声音的机器，往往会产生更大的效果。阿斯比约恩研究的大多数试验都是在测试各种药物的疗效。它们只是设置了一个安慰剂组。它们的设计并不是像特德·卡普查克那样为了引出安慰剂效应，它们没有关注治疗周围的所有仪式感。阿斯比约恩认同，像这样的研究——有时被称为主动安慰剂研究——
could produce very different results. That's because they are designed to look beyond the effective pills to activate things like the doctor patient relationship. About a year into her second round of placebo treatment, Linda ended up in the hospital for back surgery. She couldn't get to Ted's office to pick up placebo pills. She was worried her IBS would return. But it didn't. Now I don't even take place, you know what it's like to be back to normal, to have a normal life like everybody else, and never have to think once what condition you're in, or if
可能会产生截然不同的结果。那是因为它们的设计超越了药丸的效果，旨在激活医生与患者的关系等因素。在她第二轮安慰剂治疗大约一年后，琳达因背部手术住进了医院。她无法去特德的办公室拿安慰剂药丸。她担心自己的IBS会复发。但它并没有复发。现在我甚至不再吃安慰剂了，你知道回到正常状态、过上像其他人一样正常的生活、再也不用去想自己处于什么状况、
you're going to get sick or what's going to happen, it doesn't even enter my mind. When we go to a doctor, we need two different things. The first is explicit and obvious. We want someone skilled and knowledgeable who can diagnose us correctly, who knows which pills or procedures are likely to help. But we also have implicit needs. We want someone who can attend to our suffering, not just to our illness. We need someone to trust in moments of fear and vulnerability. We want more than answers.
或者自己会不会生病、会发生什么的感觉是怎样的吗？这些甚至都不会在我的脑海中浮现。当我们去看医生时，我们需要两种不同的东西。第一种是明确而显而易见的。我们需要一个技术娴熟、知识渊博的人，能够正确诊断我们，知道哪些药物或手术可能会有所帮助。但我们也有隐性的需求。我们需要有人来关注我们的痛苦，而不仅仅是我们的病情。在恐惧和脆弱的时刻，我们需要可以信任的人。我们需要的不仅仅是答案。
We want reassurance. For overworked doctors and overburdened medical systems, our explicit needs can feel more urgent than our implicit needs. Surgery and medications can see more rigorous than the techniques to address our implicit needs, acting and storytelling and rituals. On top of that, these elements of performance may feel unseemly, like the behavior of snake oil salesmen. But when both kinds of needs are met, doctors and patients are more likely to get the outcome they both want.
我们需要的是安慰。对于过度疲劳的医生和负担过重的医疗系统来说，我们明确的需求可能会比隐性的需求更显得迫切。相比于解决我们隐性需求的技术——表演、讲故事和仪式感，手术和药物似乎更加严谨。除此之外，这些表演的要素可能会显得不太体面，就像江湖郎中的行为。但是，当这两种需求都得到满足时，医生和患者更有可能获得他们都想要的结果——
Healing This week's episode was produced by Raina Cohen. It was edited by Tara Boyle and Jenny Schmidt. Special thanks this week to Path Shah and Angela C. Patrice Howard, Davis Land and Ted Meabain. Our team includes Thomas Liu, Laura Correll, Kat Chuknecht and Lushik Wabba. Our unsung heroes are Barbara Bonso and Rebecca Mervora. They work at the Wellness Center at NPR's headquarters. While most of us are working from home these days,
治愈。本周的节目由雷娜·科恩制作。由塔拉·博伊尔和珍妮·施密特剪辑。本周特别感谢帕思·沙阿、安吉拉·C·帕特里丝·霍华德、戴维斯·兰德和特德·梅班。我们的团队成员包括托马斯·刘、劳拉·科雷尔、卡特·丘克内特和露希克·瓦巴。我们无名英雄是芭拉拉·邦索和丽贝卡·梅尔沃拉。他们在NPR总部的心灵健康中心工作。虽然我们大部分人这些天都在家里办公，
it's good to note that when we return to the office, we'll have the Wellness Center staff to rely on for everything from flu shots to checkups. We're lucky to have them close by, and just as important, to have healthcare practitioners with a great bedside matter. For more hidden brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If you liked this episode, please remember to share it with a friend or with your doctor.
但值得一提的是，当我们重返办公室时，我们可以依靠心灵健康中心的工作人员，从流感疫苗到体检，一切都能得到妥善照顾。我们很幸运能有他们在附近，同样重要的是，能拥有具有极好床边态度的医疗保健从业人员。想了解更多《隐形的大脑》，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。如果你喜欢本期节目，请记得分享给朋友或你的医生。
I'm Shankar Vedantum and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是香卡·韦丹坦，这里是NPR。本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。